[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's
facts 800-463-7297
pastor doug batchelor
hello listening friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
a young boy in ontario canada real
guinean was camping with his parents and
he decided to stay on land while they
rode out into the lake for a little
fishing
tragically their boat tipped over in the
water far from shore and the boy watched
as his parents drowned
sobbing he tried walking towards a town
several miles away but as darkness fell
he knew that he'd have to spend the
night on the cold damp ground
as the temperatures had dipped below
freezing during the night he lay there
shivering and crying he felt a warm
furry body snuggle up to his back in the
dark
delirious from his ordeal and thinking
the creature must be a dog he fell
asleep
when he stiffly woke in the morning he
discovered that these three beavers had
curled up around him and kept him from
freezing to death
as he sat up they calmly waddled away
you know pastor roz that makes me think
about a number of stories in the bible
if you come to mind
how god has used animals
to keep people safe that's right
pasadena we were just talking about this
before we went on the area there's a
number of bible examples for example you
have the donkey in the case of balaam
that actually obey like that
yeah balaam's donkey that actually
protected him from an angel with the
sword and you have the whale that
swallowed jonah and you know we did an
amazing thing of course not didn't just
swallow him he put him back on dry land
yeah three-day journey
and then we did an amazing fact i
thought of as well of a i think it was a
woman that fell overboard or she was
swimming she was surrounded by sharks
and uh some dolphins came that's right
and they actually uh scared away the
sharks or butted away the sharks and
then they protected her
and uh
yeah and they boyed her up when she was
sinking you think in the bible about um
elijah how he was sustained by the the
ravens and i guess you could make an
argument that
isaac was going to be sacrificed but
they found a ram that's right to take
his place
but you know
it just reminds us that you know god
created these animals
um in many ways sometimes animals seem
to be more in tune with the leading of
the spirit and god than humans do
there's an interesting passage in the
book of job i've been reading through
job lately and it's just a
fantastic book
and it says in job 12 verse 7
but now ask the beasts and they will
teach you and the birds of the air and
they will tell you or speak to the earth
and it will teach you and the fish of
the sea will explain to you
who among all of these does not know
that the hand of the lord has done this
you can see the fingerprints of the lord
on all of creation and we can even learn
something about god and his love
through the creatures that he's made
you know we do have a book that talks
about the wonders of creation and this
is our free gift we don't always off to
the off of this book pastor dev but but
it is a great book and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
the number for the book is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
amazing wonders of creation we'll get
that in the mail we'll send it to anyone
in north america if you're outside of
north america you can just go to the
amazing facts website amazingfacts.org
and you click on the free library and
you'll be able to read the book right
there online
and also we were just informed before
the program this this is our one year
anniversary for doing bible answers live
on television of course it started as a
radio program how many years ago passed
today well it must be 27 years ago 25
years ago i forget it's been a long time
yeah and then we expanded from
land-based uh radio stations to
satellite radio and then social media
and then amazing facts tv yeah and i
think we're even looking to expand on
some other networks in this next coming
year so exciting things with bible
answers live yes and it's a joy we
always like hearing people that say they
watched the program it answered some
lifelong questions that really helped
them that's right well we've got
questions lined up if you have a
question friend the number to call is
800-463-7297 that is our phone line here
to the studio 800-463-7297
it's a good time to
pick up your phone give us a call but
before we go to the phone lines we start
we always like to start with the word of
prayer so let's do that dear father in
heaven and give me thank you for your
many blessings thank you for life and
strength and the ability to study your
word thank you for the freedom that you
have given us here in this country and
so we ask your blessing upon the program
be with us as we search the scriptures
and be with those who are listening
wherever they might be and we ask this
in jesus name amen amen okay we're ready
to go to our first call of this evening
we've got anthony listening in michigan
now anthony welcome to the program
hello sir hello pastor dev hi anthony
thank you for calling
good me on here
um great to be here again
so
my question
i'm
gonna be trying to be as quick with my
wording as i can about this
um
my sister
years ago and
i mean i don't think she had as many
reasons as somebody say joe but
i don't think she was like
too far from getting there at the same
time
um
and as far as i know sh i've never once
heard her
she didn't like
see god as her savior i never once
even saw her actually like give up just
out of frustration which i've done
myself
and
all this time i actually thought she had
a way stronger will than me and
and and what's ironic is when she died
at the age that she did a few years
before that i picked a random number
that i'd be okay with dying and it was
that one
and then i just felt bad for saying i'd
be okay with dying at this age
so
and so
your sister took her life
yeah i mean there was a there was a
bunch of times where my dad held her
accountable for things that weren't her
fault like he made her work off an
ambulance bill for the first time she
had an asthma attack um
well now
yeah god knows the circumstances so is
your concern you're wondering what does
the bible say and does this mean will
she is there hope of salvation or does
this mean she's destined to be lost is
that one you're kind of wondering
i'm
i'm kind of hoping that there's some
chance that she won't be in the great
lake of fire but
that i will see her
all right that's well that that's a
tough tough experience and you know as
pastors pastor ross and i have dealt
with families that have
experienced suicide and yes it even
happens in christian families
the first thing i would say is just keep
in mind
that god loves our friends and family
loved ones infinitely more than we do
infinitely more
he's desperate to save as many as he can
god is not willing that any should
perish
now obviously some will be saved and
some will not
and you just really can't spend time in
this life
wondering now there will be examples i'm
sure in heaven of people that took their
own lives we don't know the
circumstances
they had
you know they encountered some struggles
faith in god but something happened it
could have been physical pain or
chemical imbalance and you know god will
have to judge these things so i would
never say that that's a hopeless
situation it's usually very concerning
because often when a person takes their
life it means they've lost faith they've
lost hope and those are usually not a
good barometer of a person's spiritual
life
but i would just say put this in the
hands of the lord and do not worry
when jesus comes the bible says he will
wipe away all tears from our eyes and i
think we're going to be very surprised
when we get to heaven we're going to see
people there we never dreamed would be
there and we'll see some people missing
we might thought would be there so
don't worry about it now trust god's
goodness and his justice
and
he's got plans for your life so you live
to the fullest
mm-hmm
absolutely
and yeah we uh go goes out to you
anthony as pastor doug mentions we work
with families from time to time who've
gone through this loss and you know you
can't turn the bible says we can cast
all of our cares upon the lord for he
cares for us and yeah some of these are
difficult experiences but god knows and
understands that we can trust in him yep
yeah
well thank you
and i do have an article you'll find on
the amazing facts website you just type
in
you know doug batchelor answers on
suicide and i give more scriptures and i
go to greater length in explaining that
and you can look that up anthony and
we'll keep you in prayer that's a tough
experience
our next caller that we have is randy
listening in ohio randy welcome to the
program
ah thank you pastor ross pastor doug
my question is could you please explain
daniel
in particular where it talks about the
god of forces and the god whom his
fathers knew not
my main part is could this god of forces
possibly refer to the us
okay thank you and uh your
phone cut off for a second you're asking
us to explain daniel 11 38 if i'm not
mistaken
yes all right this is uh
i'm sorry go ahead i was just going to
spell this out for some of you i
understand
excuse me in particular where it talks
about the god of forces by god whom his
fathers knew not
if this could be the usa
all right my initial answer will be no i
don't believe this is speaking of the
usa i believe in daniel 11 it's talking
about uh a power that's also presented
in revelation chapter 17 and revelation
13.
it's this beast power that is the
commingling of religion
and
christianity and
spiritualism and government
and what
most protestant theologians identify
that with the papacy
i know martin luther and
john wesley founders of methodists
calvin the presbyterians the lutherans
uh charles spurgeon this is what they
all believe when they read those
prophecies
what it's saying here in daniel 11 38 it
says he'll not regard the god of his
fathers or the desire of women and some
have interpreted that i mean you know
the
priests do not marry
and then it says but in his estate he'll
honor the god of forces and that word
forces or fortresses
it comes from the hebrew word mahouziam
which means basically
a god it's
the gods of saints that departed and
what you see happening in catholicism is
they surround themselves with images
and saints and they pray to these saints
and they deify the dead
and they make kind of many gods out of
them
and that's the way i think many of the
reformers understood this passage so no
i don't think it's talking about the
united states
although the bible does talk about the
u.s yeah there's another prophecy on
that that's right the second beast of
revelation 13. we do have a study guide
that talks about the united states in
prophecy and you might find this
interesting randy or anyone wanting to
learn more about it you can just call
and ask the study guide's called the usa
in bible prophecy and the number for
that is 800-835-6747
and we'll be happy to send that to
anyone in north america that's
800-835-6747
we've got ken listening from new york
ken you're on bible answers live
good evening gentlemen evening thanks
for calling
thank you for having me my question is
about taken from
romans chapter 16 and one
in that passage phoebe is referred to as
a deacon or deaconess i guess
and i'm just trying to reconcile that
because i've always heard that the
deacon must be the husband of one wife
i wonder if you could shed some light on
that for me
yeah well the word deacon is is used in
a general sense you know you find the
word servant all through
the new testament and so when for our
friends that are listening the verse
that we're considering is romans 16 1.
let me read it quickly paul says i
commend to you phoebe we once had a pet
poodle named phoebe my mom liked the
name sorry
i commend to you phoebe our sister who
is a servant in the church of crenshaw
that you may receive her in the lord in
a manner worthy of saints and a sister
in whatever business she has need of you
for indeed she has been a helper and
there you've got the the definition of
servant she's been a helper of many and
myself also so there was this dear
sister in the church and she's traveling
for some reason for from one church to
another evidently she's going to uh
um
from crenshaw maybe to rome
and uh paul is saying you know treat her
well she's got our endorsement she's
been a servant
now keep in mind
paul even says that the widows who were
to receive sustenance from the church
must be genuine widows they must be
willing to be of service in the church
even says who they've washed the
apostles feet our disciples feet so the
word service here doesn't necessarily
mean a church office it means to be a
servant
and the the original word there in the
greek is also used uh can be translated
as deacon or deaconess however in this
verse it's interesting it's in the
feminine form
so more accurate if you want to
translate it into english it will be a
deaconess which is a little different
than the criteria that we find given
for a deacon which is in the masculine
sense
so we recognize in our church we have
different positions different
responsibilities we have deacons we have
deaconesses and deaconesses do serve a
very important role in the church
especially in the area of ministering to
the needs of
some of the the folks in the church
they're involved in the communion the
preparation for communion the visitation
of the sick working with the children so
there's there's many important roles
that are fulfilled by the deaconesses
right and apparently in the early
christian church we find this structure
was already in place and phoebe was very
much involved maybe as a leader amongst
the leonesses in that capacity right
which is a different definition than
when paul says the deacon must be a
husband of one wife right different
responsibilities that was the masculine
so hope that helps ken
does that make sense yes
yes it does i appreciate you guys all
right thank you so much appreciate your
call next quarter that we have is ian
listening in canada yeah and welcome to
the program you on the air
thank you so much pastor ross and pastor
doug and i just want to thank you really
quick because your programs are a huge
blessing in my life and i love watching
them
thank you and listening to them
my question is uh is this in watching
one of your programs
i thought i heard you pastor doug
mentioned something about in the last
times
that many would be called up in the
spirit of elijah so i just wanted to
clarify if if i heard that correctly and
if there's
maybe some bible verses that support
that or just generally um
where that would have came from if i did
hear that correctly
yeah well first of all you find in the
last chapter of the old testament
malachi chapter 4 some of the last
verses
jesus said first he says remember the
law of moses my servant which i gave him
in mount horeb for all israel with its
statutes and judgments
and behold i send you elijah the prophet
before the great and terrible day of the
lord come
so we know that john that john the
baptist came in the spirit and power of
elijah but that was not before the great
and terrible day of the lord
and jesus speaking of john the baptist
he said elijah has come speaking of john
he said elijah will come
so in the same way that john the baptist
came to prepare the children of israel
for the first coming of jesus
jesus seemed to imply that that same
spirit of john the baptist one calling
people to revival that will say prepare
the way of the lord make way for the
lord in the wilderness
will come again before the second coming
of jesus
and so that's an example of two of those
verses i think one is in matthew 11 and
the other i just read is malachi chapter
4.
so
and of course the angel said to
zechariah that john the baptist would go
in the spirit and power of elijah
and that's in the gospel of luke um
first chapter i believe
so
does that make sense or help a little
yeah yeah that absolutely i tried after
i heard it on the program i tried to do
some digging on my own and failed so
you gave me a great shortcut just now
thank you all right hey thank you so
much and let's all pray we can have that
spirit
that's the plan god bless you god bless
next caller that we have is uh byron
listening from canada byron welcome to
the program
hello pastor rose i am pastor dog
bless your ministry i really enjoy
watching you guys and everything that
you do
thank you my question is
what is on daniel 12
verse 12.
he's talking about bless
are those who wait
to come for the
1325 days what is the
1325 days represent
all right to understand that i'm gonna
ask pastor ross to answer it but let me
just set it up to understand that there
are three time periods given in daniel
chapter 12. and so before you can cut
off the 1335 you've got to know about
the 1260 and the 1290. so this is a
complicated prophecy it's real hard to
you know we try to budget about three
minutes for an answer it's kind of hard
to fit this all into a three-minute
answer
right you've got the 1260-year time
period which is very significant time
period that represents the reign of the
papal power during the dark ages from 5
38 until 1798 so that's 1260 years then
you have the 1290 years
which is uh when clovis uh king of the
franks was converted to christianity
and that opened up the way for paper
power in 605 no 508 508 sorry the other
one 508 um kind of opened up the way for
papal supremacy in europe and then the
1335 if you start with that same date
508 and you go forward in time you end
on the date 1843 now you might be
wondering what happened in 1843 well
there was a great revival especially in
the prophecies of daniel that occurred
around 1843-1844
and so the verse is blessed is he who
waits until that time period there was a
special manifestation of the spirit
there was revival not only in north
america but it spread to europe and even
as far away as south american missionary
outposts around the world there was a
great interest in the prophecies of
daniel in particular and so this verse
is a reference to that revival that
occurred around 1843
it's a very interesting time prophecy
and parallels or ties in with revelation
chapter 10
which also talks about that same
experience around 1844.
so i know that's a lot to take in but
you know we need to get something in
writing on that pastor ross hope that
helps a little byron you know we do have
a study guide that calls that's called
right on time i don't think he gets into
the specifics here of the 1335 and the
1290 but it does talk about the 1260 and
give you the historical evidence for the
start of that time period so that might
be of interest and we'll be happy to
send that to anyone who calls an assets
uh number is eight 1-800-835-6747
you can ask for the study guide it's
called write on time
next quality that we have is joel
listening in north carolina joel welcome
to the program
hi pastor doug pastor ross hi
and your question uh my question is
about ezekiel chapter 1 26-28
is this talking about god the father or
god the son all right let me read this
for our listeners we always try to be
mindful that a lot of the folks
listening are driving
and they can't just stop and look it up
and above the firmament over their heads
was the likeness of a throne in
appearance like a sapphire stone
and on the likeness of the throne was
the likeness with the appearance of a
man high above it also from the
appearances of his waist upward i saw as
it were the color of amber with the
appearance of fire all around within it
and from the appearance of his waist and
downward i saw as it were the appearance
of fire with brightness all around it
like the appearance of a rainbow in a
cloud on a rainy day so was the
appearance of brightness all around it
this was the appearance of the likeness
of the glory of the lord
well
i think most people reading this are
scholars anyway they they see a
similarity between this passage and what
you find in revelation 1 where jesus
appears to john
and so we believe this would be a god
the son in his glory and keep in mind
that bible says no man has seen the
father
so if ezekiel saw this vision
he's probably seen god the son
it's also interesting you've got a
parallel with revelation chapter four
where it describes the heavenly throne
room and some of the similarities it's a
sea here it's talking about the blue the
color of the stone it's talking about a
rainbow surrounding the throne a lot of
perils between revelation 4 and what we
see over here in ezekiel that's right
all right thank you for your call next
quarter that we have is john listening
in washington john welcome to the
program
yes thank you for taking my call
um my question is uh regarding use of
the
phrase in in set in funerals
of uh ashes to ashes dust to dust
and if that comes from a scripture i'd
like to know what it is
and also any scripture that would
pertain to uh
cremation
okay the the scripture and the word
ashes and dust is synonymous in i think
in hebrew and when god said to adam and
i believe pastor ross said to genesis 3
he said dust you are and unto dust you
will return
and then when you you're inquiring about
cremation what does the bible say about
this we it's a good question because
something everyone deals with at some
point
and
i'll give you a little shameless plug
here is i did a video on that because we
received that question too much
and it's called to bury or to burn if
you go to youtube you can see it for
free and i take a lot of scripture or
take more time there than i i would have
here
but in a quick answer i would say
a predominantly in the bible the example
you see is for burial
i don't think this is a salvation issue
where if a person is cremated instead of
buried they can't be saved because many
christians were burnt at the stake
there are two examples of people we know
that were cremated in the bible that
you've got jonathan who is the son of
king saul dear friend of david
and
he was cremated and we fully expect to
see him in the resurrection
his was not a martyr's death he wasn't
cremated by the enemy but
his own people when his his body had
been mutilated in a battle
they took his remains and cremated him
um
and of course it was father king saul
but he's not going to make it as far as
we can tell
anyway but um i thought there was one
other example
so
um
yeah typically in the bible i can
understand the practicality of it i
think in tokyo right now virtually
everybody is cremated because they just
don't have space for
graveyards and in america now all the
the graveyard space is being taken up by
golf courses so they have very little
space left
for
graveyards in north america so more
people are turning to cremation
and i think somebody's certainly cheaper
it is cheaper
uh cremation almost speeding up the
process of burial i mean if somebody's
buried long enough
you know maybe all that's left is bones
you might say but
um cremation speeds up accelerates
the decomposition process okay well
thank you for your call our next caller
that we have is we've got benita
listening in north carolina benita
welcome to the program
bonita you there she might be on mute
vanita you're on the air
i need all right we might want to come
back to bonita
there you are hello
bonita we thank you are you there
all right we might come back you know
pastor i'm looking at the clock i don't
know do we have time to take another
call we'll try a quick one all right
we've got scott listening in florida
scott we got about a minute a minute and
a half before the break
hi how are you good how can we help you
today master bachelor you'll be in my
neighborhood this week coming up but um
my question is not a good one-minute
question but uh it was about the two
witnesses and i've been studying really
hard on it
and i've come up the
um
two that i think they are and i have
pretty good
feelings about it you know praying with
the holy spirit is
it's the jews and the gentiles that
represent the two witnesses what do you
think
all right yeah i appreciate that uh i
would say that uh when i read it these
two witnesses that
are by the throne of god is a parallel
for what you find in zechariah it talks
about the two witnesses by the throne
the candlesticks typically they're
understood to be the law and the
prophets or the word of god
and that is a witness they you know
jesus said in the mouth of two witnesses
christ rose from the dead and it says
speaking from the law and the prophets
he taught them that he was the messiah
you might say moses and elijah appeared
to jesus on the mountain moses
represents the law elijah represents the
prophets and i think pastor ross we even
have a book on this that we could send
to
scott
and
for free he can actually read it online
talks about the glorious mount
who are the two witnesses the number to
call for that is
800-835-6747 you can just simply call
and ask for the book on the two
witnesses called the glorious mount
we'll be happy to send it to anyone in
north america yeah sorry to cut that
question short scott take a look at the
book and let us know if that helps a
little bit and you keep studying
listening friends we're not done we're
just taking a brief break we're going to
come back
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
millions of people believe that planet
earth is on the verge of some apocalypse
that will plunge the world cities into
chaos
in response
thinking people everywhere are wondering
if it might be a good time to locate
their families outside of the congested
metropolitan areas
in my new book heading for the hills a
beginner's guide to country living i do
my best to provide a biblical balance
i'd like to share with you some of the
crucial things you'll need to know
before you head up for the hills
i'd also like to identify some of the
practical things you look for in buying
a piece of country land how to develop
water power and a garden all while still
seeking to save the lost this book has
some very valuable information for
anybody that's ever considering country
living
order your copy of heading for the hills
call 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
what if you could know the future
what would you do
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a military prodigy
150 years in advance cyrus had been
named
rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
this intriguing documentary hosted by
pastor doug batchelor explores the most
striking bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time
are you ready
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live and some have tuned in
along the way this is a live
international interactive bible study
you interact by calling in with your
bible questions the number is 800 god
says that's 463
and i am doug batchelor my name is john
ross and we have a number of folks who
have called in and they ready with their
bible questions so we'll go to bonita uh
and uh benita listening in north
carolina bonita you there
i am
hi you on the air
thank you
ever since i was probably four i came to
understand that god
can read our minds and knows what our
thoughts are but the devil cannot
and so i've always
had a much
better comfortability
with praying
through thought rather than verbally
unless it's in a public setting is there
anything wrong with that
no there's examples in the bible i know
in the book of nehemiah it tells us that
nehemiah obviously he prayed in his
heart he was about to answer the king
and he wasn't sure what to say and he's
standing there so he prays in his heart
god tells us he knows what things we
have need of before we even ask
and the bible tells us in first kings
chapter eight i think it's verse 39 that
god and god only knows the thoughts of
men's hearts so the devil can't read our
minds only god can do that
a people can guess what someone else is
thinking and the devil is probably very
good at that looking at body language
but only god really knows the heart but
there is nothing wrong with praying out
loud i think there's power sometimes in
praying out loud we have some wonderful
prayers in the bible that are recorded
from jesus and daniel and mary and
abraham and others because they prayed
out loud they're recorded so
you know when you pray out loud i think
angels surround you when jesus was in
the garden of gethsemane he prayed not
my will thy will be done and then you've
got that beautiful prayer in john 17
that's recorded because obviously the
lord prayed out loud
so
don't be afraid to do that i think the
devil trembles when you pray out loud
but there's certainly nothing wrong with
praying in your heart i probably do most
of my praying that way
because you walk and talk to the lord
when you're praying in your heart
we've got a book it's called teach us to
pray and it lays out some of these
biblical principles that uh talk about
prayer we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
four 800-835-6747 and again just ask the
book it's called teach us to pray and
we'll send it to anyone in north america
thank you for your call benita we've got
rich listening in michigan rich welcome
to the program
rich in michigan are you ready muted
rich
rich one more time
all right while we wait there let's go
to uh yolanda in arizona yolanda welcome
to the program
hello
hi thanks for calling hi
hi thank you for taking my call um
my family and i have been studying the
last day events
and so i have a question in the last day
of ends when satan appears as the false
christ will that be before or after the
close of probation
oh good question well
first of all once probation closes
the saved or saved and the lost are lost
right we understand that right i can't
understand why the devil would save his
masterpiece of deception
for a time when it was too late to make
any difference
so i think it's immediately prior to the
close of probation that he pulls out his
best game plan and tries to impersonate
christ
so
you know that's why what jesus warns his
disciples there will be false christs
and false prophets
if uh if their salvation is all secure
before they come then
they won't really need to worry about
that
but he tells him
through history for that matter but yeah
i'm talking about the ultimate deception
of satan where he impersonates christ
i think is uh just before the close of
probation when he's hoping to accomplish
the most damage
yeah but you would think that okay i can
see it go both ways so when it's um
so you're saying it's after or before
i'm thinking that and you know i could
be wrong on this but my understanding is
that satan is going to reserve that
masterpiece of deception
for
a time when it's going to still have an
impact
and that's why jesus warns do not go
forth if someone says here is christ or
there
so the church is being warned against
that deception if all the saved are
saved
and the loss of loss and probation is
closed then there's really no risk of
anybody being deceived by that
okay so so you're saying before
yeah i think shortly before
because you would think if it's after
that he would still try one more time
because it says that no one will know
the hour the day or the hour or well
when he comes but also too he doesn't
know when to close up and i'm talking
about satan he doesn't know the days
or the the moment when
when probation closes so you would think
at the end
um after probation closes that he would
try and attempt the
the
god's people well you see once probation
once probation closes i'm actually doing
this study on this tomorrow morning uh
once probation closes you've got the
great tribulation the seven last plagues
are falling
right and i think people are going to be
so distracted by the plagues you know
they're going to just be cursing god
so
now jesus says that the deception in the
last days will be so effective that if
it were possible even the very elect
would be deceived so god preserves the
elect from being deceived
but uh i think the door is probably
still open that's why the lord is
warning about that
but anyway again i'm speculating a
little bit because there's no as far as
i know there's no what do you call it a
decisive comment on that in the bible
you just kind of have to do some
detective work and make your make an
educated guess
right okay so i i i thought i heard you
mention that you're doing this tomorrow
well yeah i will recording tomorrow
it'll actually be on youtube so i'm
doing a three-part series on the kind of
the three phases of the tribulation the
great tribulation that are spoken
in
uh what do you call it matthew 24. so
yeah watch for that it'll be on the
youtube doug batchelor amazing facts
channel
okay something thank you so much all
right thank you
all right next caller that we have is
we'll try rich again in michigan rich um
welcome to the program can you hear me
yes can you hear me
yeah you're here now you're on all right
yes yes all right i've been listening to
you guys for a while now but um the
other day something struck me i was
listening i don't know if you guys are
somebody else but they said that when we
die we're sleeping
and
you know if we die in christ we're
sleeping in christ and we don't know the
time or anything until he comes back the
second time
to collect us you know
but then in the bible
you know it says that the rich man at in
lazarus they were he was at the gate
begging and they both died and landed
lazarus was in abraham's bosom
but the rich man went to hell or
whatever
haiti let me take a drip water let him
put a different water on my finger and
guys says no the
thing is too wide you had your chance
and blew it right now that says right
there
that we didn't just go to hell away i
mean in our grave and waiting for him to
come
we're alive and going somewhere else or
all right let's talk about it i'm kind
of confused on that one yeah yeah no
problem uh so when we're talking about
the rich man and lazarus this is a
passage you find in luke chapter i think
it's 16 verse 19
and it's a parable and you've got
parables around it
and one reason we know it's a parable is
there's nowhere else in the bible that
says
all of those that die go to abraham's
bosom
so here's what jesus is teaching in that
parable he's warning the jewish nation
that was rich in truth and feasting on
the word of god they were not loving or
caring about the gentiles begging for
the crumbs that fell from their table
the gentiles their place of punishment
was called hades
the jews their place of reward was to be
with abraham
and so what jesus does is he tells this
parable and he switches
places he's got the rich man going to
the gentile place of torment and he's
got the poor gentile beggar lazarus he's
going to the rich man's to the jewish
place of reward
and christ is saying
that if you do not believe moses and the
prophets you want to be persuaded that
one should rise from the dead
of course jesus did rise from the dead
the religious leaders did not believe he
even rose someone from the dead by the
name of lazarus
and they did not believe so this is a
parable it's not talking about the state
of man and death because think about it
will the people in heaven be able to
talk to the people burning in hell
no i don't think so well you can't take
that literally
would one drop of water really cool them
no that's another though yeah so that's
full of memories
because you'll be in heaven you'll be in
paradise with me today
yeah actually if you look at that
uh you know there's no punctuation in
the original what jesus said is verily i
say to you today
you will be with me in paradise
christ could not have been with the
thief in paradise that day because you
read in john chapter 20 when christ
rises from the dead he tells mary
magdalene do not cling to me do not
touch me i have not yet ascended to my
father
so christ is telling mary sunday morning
he still hasn't ascended to the father
how could he be with the thief in
paradise friday afternoon
right that's why i'm in trouble
so you know you've got a lesson on that
we do appreciate it yeah you know the
thief talking about the thief he wasn't
expecting to go to paradise that day
because he said to jesus lord remember
me when you come in your kingdom so he
was looking forward to the second coming
of christ and saying lord remember me
and so christ assured him that day that
he would be in the future with him in
paradise and that's the assurance that
we can have
right away when we receive jesus
so we we do go to sleep then and we're
not i mean we're just asleep there until
he does come we don't know the time
passes yeah but
you know for a believer
a believer it says to be absent from the
bodies be present with the lord if
you're saved and you die your next
conscious thought is the resurrection so
there's no consciousness of time for you
well actually because we're we're asleep
anyway we're sleeping
it's a totally dreamless sleep you know
it's not like you sleep uh where you you
know roll over during the night you have
no awareness of time one let me give you
more proof of that
king david died 3000 years ago the bible
says david slept with his fathers acts
chapter 2 a thousand years later peter
says david is dead and buried and not
ascended to heaven his tomb is with us
to this day he couldn't be any more
clear he's dead he's in the grave he's
not yet ascended to heaven this is after
the resurrection
so
but for david who died his next
conscious thought is the presence of the
lord
the resurrection
yeah you look in first thessalonians
chapter 4
says the lord himself will descend from
heaven with a shout then the dead in
christ will rise first so when does that
happen
when the lord descends from heaven with
a shout
you know rich we got a
study guide that if you haven't seen
it's just packed with scripture it's a
great study it's called how the dead
really dead and we'll be happy to send
this to you or anyone who calls and asks
the number is 800-835-6747
just call and ask are the dead really
dead we'll send it to you again it's
800-835-6747
and if you want to learn more about it
you can just go to the amazing facts
website as well and we have a number of
articles actually passed today we got a
website that amazing facts has sponsored
called
deathtruth.com that's right and it's got
a lot of scriptures there and i think
that study is even available
for people to read so take a look at
deathtruth.com
there's actually some videos some
sermons there and i think you'll be
blessed by that thank you for your call
rich we've got hector listening in
florida hector welcome to the program
thank you for taking my call uh yes i
would love to know um something about uh
revelation 12 9 to 13.
my question about this is
how
how how the the title of lucifer has
been changed from lucifer to satan or
devil
or or
or an ancient serpent
where he didn't even reach to the earth
as he had to to persecute the people was
on earth
and uh and then and also the second
question that i have and that's in that
uh
reference
um
how could uh it get cast out directly to
the earth all right
let's talk about that and the question
is here in revelation chapter 12 i think
you said verses 9
uh through at least 11 and it says so
that great dragon was cast out of that
serpent of old called the devil and
satan so right there is a very
interesting passage because it
identifies the dragon the serpent the
devil and satan
that's all talking about the same person
and then you also mentioned he's before
his fall he was called lucifer which is
lightbearer
he was the shining one of god before
this
and it says he's cast out to the earth
okay so it starts out that he rebels and
he's cast out of heaven ultimately he's
cast of the earth the reason he's cast
of the earth and restricted here and you
can read in the book of job satan says
i've come from the earth
from walking to and fro and up and down
in it
and so
here on the earth satan found
creatures intelligent creatures made in
god's image
a world where they were willing to
listen to him instead of god
whoever you obey romans chapter 6 that's
whose servant you are and when adam and
eve decided to listen to the
devil when god said do not eat the fruit
the devil said go ahead eat it they
listen to the devil kind they basically
surrendered dominion of this planet to
the enemy
so he was cast out and restricted to
this planet and this world with all his
misery and suffering is because it has
been a beach head
for the devil's campaign against god
and the whole universe is seen and the
unfallen angels
what the result of satan's government is
and all the misery and the suffering in
this world as a result of that
now we have a dvd called cosmic conflict
that
outlines this whole battle i think the
dvd is available on youtube actually i
think somebody's put it up there and it
gets into this you know just two quick
things i want to add to that past today
if you're looking verse um
in verse 9 it says so the great the
great dragon was cast out
and then you look a little further
and verse 10 says he was cast down to
the earth so there's two things there's
casting out and is casting down he's
cast out of heaven well that occurred
before the creation of the earth but
after adventure adam and eve uh sinned
he claimed dominion of the earth but in
a special way he was cast down at the
cross when jesus was victorious and
overcame
it was very evident that he had lost the
battle he's going around like a roaring
lion seeking whom he can divide he knows
he has a short time so there's the
casting out of heaven then there's the
casting down to the earth when adam and
eve chose him above god
and then in a secondary sense at the
cross christ overcame me one more time
yeah so there's two two words that's
interesting to note and jesus said uh i
saw satan fall like lightning from
heaven so
you know it's no question he's been cast
down yep great question hector thank you
for your call
um next quarter that we have is jeannie
listening in kansas genie welcome to the
program
hi hi
um
i don't know if you'd call it a question
or a comment but uh
okay pastor ross i'm not trying to leave
you out but i'm going to ignore you
because i want to talk to peter that's
fine
because he's uh
no in i don't know maybe three or four
of your programs pastor doug uh you know
you commented
naturally people wonder about the ark of
the covenant and
you've speculated you know that um
you think that they hid it in one of the
many tombs around jerusalem
but i was just wondering
um
i know it doesn't say anything in the
bible about it so i was just wondering
if you had read early writings page 32
about yeah about the law of god being
exalted
yeah
you're talking about where the law of
god is exalted
you some are some people are wondering
if um
the ark is going to be
discovered there's that verse in
revelation where it's i saw heaven open
and the ark of the covenant is that
revelation 11 revelation 11 yes the
sounding of the seventh trumpet yeah
um
does that mean that the ark's going to
be discovered i think it's saying that
the law of god is going to be exalted i
don't know what you think about that
pastor ross well first let me back up
before you answer that
so she's asking why do you think it
might be in a cave around jerusalem
well the reason is the ark is still
in the
temple
the the ten commandments are still in
the ark and the ark is still in the
temple
prior to the destruction of jerusalem by
nebuchadnezzar that's recorded
and it says nothing was in the ark but
the tables of stone the something that
happened to the pint of manna and
aaron's rod
and it never appears as one of the
articles that is carried off by
nebuchadnezzar and it never appears when
ezra brings back the articles
it's disappeared from history the only
thing that can happen is jeremiah who
foretold
the destruction of jerusalem he was some
other priests
or he directed some priests they hid it
so that the babylonians would not get
their hands on it when they conquered
the city and it's never been recorded
since then
so and you're going to say now what does
it mean there in
revelation 11 when it talks about the
ark yeah here's the verse revelation 1
verse 19 it says the temple of god is
opening heaven and the ark of his
covenant was seen in his temple there
were lightnings noises slenderings
earthquake and great hail it's the
elevation of god's law that's what's so
important about the ark of the covenant
and of course the great original of the
law is in heaven in the heavenly
sanctuary and the copy that moses had
made or god wrote
and moses put in the golden box and
is hidden somewhere near jerusalem
you'll pass it out i hope you know we i
don't know for sure but i sure hope they
do find that before jesus comes that
would be the great the greatest
archaeological find i don't know his ark
either ark would be great that would be
great but the pain commandments
and look inside and see you know where
god wrote with his own hand of course
movies have been made about that but to
actually uh see the golden box would be
a glorious thing
it's quite possible it's there we know
it's there yeah it's it's hidden
somewhere and maybe it will be found
some people claim they have found it but
you know there's all kinds of stories
out there yeah
anyway yes great question thank you
thank you
the next caller that we have is uh mary
listening in oregon mary welcome to the
program
uh thank you for taking my call and
thank you so much for all the work you
do for jesus
my question is um
about idolatry um on um
my friend was telling me that
that having a picture of jesus in the
sanctuary is is idolatry
and she
directed me to
isaiah 44
9 to 19
and it does say
idolatry is foolishness right so i was
wondering uh what
what is it on
what is it really saying
um it's it's really having a picture of
jesus is it idolatry well it could be uh
whether it's a picture which is one
dimensional or a statue which is
three-dimensional you can worship either
now folks might be shocked to hear me
say
the ten commandments the second
commandment does not forbid
the making of a facsimile or an image a
likeness
it says you shall not make a likeness
and bow down to it
an example of that would be
when the children of israel were bitten
by snakes in the book of numbers
moses was instructed to make a bronze
serpent well that would be an image
but years later when the people were
praying to it hezekiah grounded to
powder
god told
solomon
and and moses
in the temple they had angels on the ark
well you could say that angel's an idol
well it's just it was to represent the
angels of god in heaven nobody was
praying to the angels
but if someone should start praying to a
statue or painting of an angels or a
statue or a painting of jesus or mary
that becomes idolatry
there's one church that says that they
say you're not even supposed to have a
photograph of your family on the coffee
table or the wall because that's an idol
well hopefully nobody's praying to that
so
idolatry is making an image and praying
to it when you read in the bible solomon
filled with the holy spirit built the
temple
in jerusalem
there were 12 calves that held up the
altar of water the labor
and they called it the sea because it
was such a big
compartment
well there's nothing wrong with that
nobody prayed to them
so
having a likeness of something whether
it's a figure a pomegranate or
a
calf as they had there as long as they
weren't praying to it it wasn't
technically wrong
so hopefully that helps and isaiah of
course is just he's highlighting how
foolish it is to make an idol and pray
to it
we should not pray to or worship you
know representations if it's going to
make somebody stumble don't put a
picture of jesus in your house
or a statue that's right
all right well thank you for your call
mary we gonna go to um jose in tennessee
jose welcome to the program
hey how's it going uh password again
ross uh i just wanna say thank you so
much for
uh your program it's really helped me
during some very difficult times um and
yeah my question is on first timothy
uh chapter four and verse three says
forbidding to mary and commanding to
abstain from meat
which god had created to be received
with thanksgiving
of them which believe and know the truth
i know that
you know in in paradise and
and in the garden that nothing was
created to be eaten except for you know
the uh the fruits of the trees and and
things like that so i'm kind of confused
on what paul is talking about here i
also know that the background is a
little bit on you know gnosticism and
um they were restricting people from
eating certain things so can you kind of
clear that up for me yeah well i think
that what paul is specifically talking
about here is in the early church
the jewish christians
were telling the gentile converts to
christianity they could not eat any of
the meats and they're talking about
clean meats
that were sold in the roman or greek
market places because they used to
always sacrifice them before an awesome
idol or altar it was just typical in the
butcher shops they saw this has been
sacrificed to god
and paul said whatever you buy in the
flea market in the meat market eat it
don't ask any questions for conscience
saying he says the idol is nothing
but if it bothers your conscience don't
eat it
and
he says that there will be some in the
last days that will be departing from
the faith saying you cannot eat certain
means which are sanctified by the word
of god now the bible says there are
certain clean meats you can eat there's
some churches that say you can can't eat
fish on certain days of the week i think
you know what i'm talking about
and so um
you know clearly
the
ideal diet for man in the beginning in
heaven and even in this life is the diet
that god gave adam and eve and we've got
a lesson that talks about that called um
god's god's health plan free health plan
yes and if you'd like to receive that
the number to call is
of course we'll be 800-835-6747 to send
it to anyone here in north america if
you're outside of north america you can
just go to the amazing facts website
just
amazingfacts.org and you'll be able to
read the study guide there as well
pastor doug i'm looking at the clock
we've got a special session following we
say goodbye to our satellite radios here
in just a minute but stay around friends
we're going to take some of your
internet questions that you have emailed
to us uh we call it our rapid fire bible
question section so we'll be back in
just a moment
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
[Music]
hello friends welcome back to our
special segment where we take your uh
internet questions your email questions
and we try to answer as many as we can
in the time that's allotted if you'd
like to email a bible question to bible
answers live it's just simply bal
questions at amazingfacts.org
that's bal questions at amazingfacts.org
all right pastor here's the first
question that we have somebody is asking
how do i convince my family members that
their dead
loved ones cannot talk to them
and then as part two of that question
are psychics bad
okay that that's they're both sort of
related to the subject of death uh you
know if you look in the book of
ecclesiastes chapter nine
here and oh you can go to verse five it
says for the living know that they will
die but the dead know nothing and they
have no more reward for the memory of
them is forgotten their love their
hatred their envy is now perished never
more will they have a share in anything
done under the sun that means in this
life when people die they never come
back the bible does never says anything
about living who die and come back to
haunt
job says i think it's chapter 14 man
dies his sons come to honor and he does
does not know it
uh psalm 146 put not your trust in
princes or in the son of man in whom
there is no help his
breath goes forth he returns to the
earth and that very day his thoughts
perish they're not thinking anything you
need a brain to think and the brain
decomposes you don't think
and so until you get your glorified body
you're not haunting anybody and that's
at the resurrection the second coming so
no and psychics if people are consulting
with the dead
the bible tells us very clearly new and
old testament among the people in the
lake of fire are the spiritualists
and moses is pretty clear have nothing
to do with the medium that's
communicating with the dead it's usually
satanic all right here is a question
that we're hearing a lot about in the
news today the question simply is is the
bible pro-life or pro-choice
well though you know people like the
slogans of course you would think god
wants people to have life and of course
you would think god wants people to have
choice so let's set aside the the the
labels that are used to define these two
categories the real question is
when does life begin in this human life
sacred
uh the only place that you can say when
life begins human life is that
conception that's why they call it
conception
and in the bible when
the holy spirit came on mary she
conceived and it says that holy one that
is within you so human life begins at
conception it is sacred and should be
treated and protected as such
now we're really out of time
god bless friends till next week bible
answers live honest and accurate answers
to your bible questions
[Music]